So speaking of how to get started uh
this is just some 101 ideas that I've
picked up uh at juggling festivals first
off this is a pendulum POI um this is
from a hybrid of vendors but it's a
contact ball or a you know stage ball in
the end and fairly thick rope right into
a handle so it's almost kind of One
Piece feeling uh no
swivels and I'll make a link to homop
poy I've got they have some po like this
and I've got a referral program with
them to save 5% support me but uh also
feel free to post your favorite vendors
there's a bunch who make a awesome
pendulum poy so share your favorites
well the next thing with one po place
you want to start is uh typically with a
no spin throw where you're just having
the PO head and the handle go up
together and come down together which is
easier said than
done what's great about this is it
teaches you to control uh what the head
of the pl does and what the tail does
and then everything you do from there
onward becomes a choice a common one
would be making a
180° of spin in the air so it comes
leaves your hand here comes down here
and that really is all about the Finesse
of how the handle leaves your hand but
you can go so many places I I remember
watching Ronin who's done a lot of
incredible throw work uh first time I
saw people doing really great throws
with Po and you know he does all kinds
of things he throws and puts a
horizontal spin um and I've seen people
throw you put Back Spin there's so much
you can do but it's all based on having
this as the starting point oh much
harder in my left hand that's for
sure okay like I said I have a lot to
practice um when you got that working on
180° where it leaves and you catch it Le
Starts Here finishes there it's also
great to choose whether the PO drifts uh
horizontally for instance I could choose
to have it not drift at all where it
comes straight up and straight down and
it's turning around the center of its
own
tether you can also choose to have it
carry through space where it starts over
here and finishes over there and maybe I
jump over my arm in the
process which brings us to the last 101
ID to share that the kind of thing I
think Drew Bachelor talks about a lot
and he'll talk about don't worry so much
about catching don't get good at
catching get good at throwing often
you'll see people doing tosses and they
kind of they throw and then they catch
it and they throw and then they catch it
and it's all they're always reaching and
grabbing which if that's the style you
want power to you um it's not the style
I want the style I want is I throw it
such that it
lands in the catching hand that means
I'm getting get it throwing a good way
to practice that is that you don't try
not to move this hand what I want to do
is I want to throw it's hard to not
catch
but if I don't move the hand I see okay
I could have thrown 4
more I
throw and that went 2 in too
[Music]
far so that if I stop grabbing for it um
or even if I do wait for the last moment
I'm paying attention to what went wrong
with the throw for me this is going to
lead to eventually consistently doing
these rainbow throws that I quite like
um and I want to be able to do them two
po at a time and have them both land in
the fir hand um like I controlled it
with my mind so I hope that gives uh
people something to start with if you're
new at this um and like I said if you're
not doing this um post away your
favorite artists that we can follow
[Music]